loved you on that show as Bobby yes I
did I got a concussion on that show
doing action stuff how
so I you know I ducked as the stunt guy
uh did a move too soon and it was right
on the back of my head and it was one of
my batons and it just went down they
still had it on video it was crazy how
fast I went down and it wasn't until
years later because I have an eye thing
from it like I have a floating thing
that they found out that I had gotten a
concussion I still I kept I kept doing
the action stuff did you ever get money
from that settlement no no oh it's years
later it's fine hey guys I'm doing
another live podcast downtown LA at the
Regent Theater and my special guest for
January 24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking
Bad Jessica Jones this is going to be a
sold out event I know it it's going to
be exciting and uh there's a meet and
greet and so much fun that's going to
happen January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you have
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited